well today today we're going to explore
chemistry and our guide is dr. Iona
black professor black is a much beloved
professor at Yale University in the
chemistry department and shortly you'll
see why now some cool things about her
she's going to tell you about the
science but I'm going to tell you what I
think why she think why she's so cool
first of all her hometown is New Jersey
which is a home state of New Jersey
which is mine as well so that's why she
has been at Yale for about 11 years and
what's interesting is that some of her
hobbies are that she likes to dance she
likes to travel and she likes to skydive
so you can ask her about that after the
lecture as well so without further ado
let's welcome dr. black to the podium
well um good morning I have to say good
morning also so today we're going to
talk a little bit about having good
chemistry the formation and analysis of
compounds so I work with a couple of
different metals but i figured that
everybody recognizes platinum because of
the bling bling people right everybody
knows flattened so what is it it's a
metal that's 35 times more rare than
gold and is used in jewelry and it's why
because it's strong and resistant we
have it as a catalytic converter in our
cars and medicine it can be used for
dental stuff and blood evaluation and
living tissues and in pacemakers so we
see that that's a multi-faceted metal I
have periodic tables for everybody so if
I can have somebody to help give them
out when you look at the periodic table
platinum is number 78 and all this stuff
you'll learn later on but the important
part is that all these metals have
electrons and we talked about what are
the outermost electrons well in the
middle we have 10 electrons that are
animals but this D can have 10 and the S
can have two so we see there's at least
one electron that doesn't have a pair
in the complexes I'm going to talk about
here are those eight electrons because
we had to lose two and we'll get to that
a little later on but take note of the
color because the color is important so
there are some cancer drugs that are
made with flattened the earliest one was
cisplatin and here we have platinum we
have two groups that we call a means and
we have two chlorides from the periodic
table and the new one of the newer drugs
is carbo platinum well a major
difference is I can lose these chlorides
but here it will be a little more
challenging to lose something to link on
to something else so the drug that I
deal with a lot is cisplatin so it was
discovered by Rosenberg and it's good
because it's used for it some tumors so
which kind of tumors is it good for it's
good for tumors of cancer the skin the
bladder that you read through ovarian
lot some lung some bone some nasal and
some thyroid so when you see something
that's useful it also has a bad side and
that bad side is that it's not selective
weird targets so it can give you kidney
damage it can have bone marrow
suppression you can get nausea it can
affect your hearing so some concerns
about that cisplatin and drug which
arose is that it concentrates in the
liver and intestines and kidneys if you
have kidney trouble you can't use it if
you have bone marrow suppression you
can't use it and if you're young it can
make you infertile so people are always
looking trying to design something
better well in order to design something
better we have to look at what's there
that's what i like to do find out what's
going on so that's this platinum what
really does that look like so can I have
three volunteers to come up okay come
one two three good come up
so you're going to have to take off your
yukon hat for a second is that okay
alright so i'll make you platinum so I
don't you stand out here you have to
stand a little bit more to the front I'm
going to make you and a mean so you hold
the shoulder put this on his shoulder
and whole deal in and you'll be the
other Amin on his shoulder know this
person shoulder because he's platinum
he's the important one so I need you to
stick your arm I take your hat I need
you to stick your arms out so here's the
platen here's the two amines and his
arms are the two chlorides well why did
I not put anybody here because these can
change this is the easiest part to pluck
off which is the chlorides okay thank
you I'm going to have to call you back
later so when we bind we can get up to
four Platinum's in a rule and that would
be important a little later on we'll
come back to that so when I go back what
are these circle things these circle
things are what we call ligands and so
what we need to do is change those
circle things so in the literature there
was a professor from Germany named
Bernhardt lip art and he took this
molecule and this one and coupled it or
put it together with platinum so what's
the major difference between these two
is this little thing sticking out here
with it which is a ch3 so sometimes when
we do synthesis we have to look at what
can we change where can we change it and
what would be the effect so both of
these are six membered rings there was a
professor at Harvard professor lip hard
and he took this molecule and made a
complex and the one that you saw earlier
with four Platinum's I was a very famous
one which he did now what's the
difference between these two well as
this bond here and this von here so one
of the ideas
I had was okay let's see if this thing
will bond to the platinum so you can
take what's existing in literature and
see if you can modify it to get
something better what's the major
difference between these two and the
others well I see that now I have a
five-membered ring instead of a sixth
and the difference between these is this
group right here which is a ch3 so now
I've made a series as analogous to the
six-membered ring and here's one of my
claims of things nobody had bothered to
look at this compound so it has the same
basic structure with the blue which is
where things are going to come together
and I wanted to see will that have the
same kind of reaction as others we can
even get more complicated and this is
true because when we there are some
other complexes which are antibiotics
I'll talk about in a little bit and they
have some of the same structure with
some changes so coming back to our
original complex which was for
Platinum's in a row so can I have my
three original volunteers and I need
three more volunteers okay I need two
more come on come on okay yes and nobody
from the back of the room one person
from the back come on one more person
okay my three original volunteers who
are you you have to take your hat off
again okay put your hat back on you have
to stand to the front and my other two
you're going to take this same position
so now we have some new platinum people
you all are platinum so put these hats
on so now you're going to use one of
your hands you're going to hold one part
is you're going to hold the other know
with your other hand and with this one
you're going to take this you're going
to take that part so what do we have now
we have four Platinum's in a row and
behind each one of those Platinum's we
have to imines so now can I have six
more people other six more people to
link them wow I can't believe people
don't want to come okay so you're going
to be behind this young lady and you're
going to represent the amines this guy
I'm sorry and you're going to act just
like that I mean and you're going to be
on this person shoulder no more no more
okay no we need two on each other so we
need one more there and one more on this
shoulder right here so we see it's
getting kind of crowded here right okay
so what can happen well right now all
those Platinum's look alike because they
all have on the same hat but what kind
of complex I get will depend on what
that platinum looks like so I need you
to drop this and you move ship that way
a little bit so the first kind of thing
we can get which is called the dimer
it's a dimer because I have two
Platinum's and they're bound together
and then i have the amines and stuff on
the back of them so that complex is
yellow so what can happen now i can get
for platinum so shift over come over but
now she's changed so that's the second
complex so what does this complex look
like those three platinum are alike and
I have one that's different well that
complex is going to be blue and those
are note there's a whole class of
compounds that are like that which are
called platinum blues what happens if
now I change the character of that one
which is the example here now instead of
being blue in color I'm tan in color and
I can go where you're going to break
apart
and we have the very last instance which
is the platinum that complex is red okay
let's say thank you to the volunteers
and you may keep your gifts that you
have so just like there's a lot of
people it's very crowded in that small
space well making those complexes is
also whose face is crowded so the my
first volunteer to arms are these two
electrons right here remember that's the
one that the CAD the chlorides and that
can go away it has to go away in order
to make a complex so just imagine that I
have my for Platinum's they have their
two arms out oh oh anybody in here play
soccer all right I got injured so now I
can't use two arms I can only use one
arm so that's what this missing space
here is my arm is injured or that
electron has been kicked out so again
we're coming back to the two drugs which
we have and so this is the one that I'm
going to talk about a little bit so how
once i have that complex how do i use it
with the ligand well first this is a
solid that's yellow this is a solid
that's white so if i put two solids
together unless i do it under high
pressure in certain conditions i'm not
going to get a reaction so i put some
water in there certain amount make a
certain concentration and i have to do
it in the dark and when i do what do I
have I done I pull these two chlorides
off and I replaced them with water I've
made this compound and I know what that
is because it settles to the bottom this
is a white compound that just falls out
so I can separate this compound from
that one this is a liquid this is a
solid I do what we call filtering
and then all I'm interested in is the
one that's a liquid then I take that and
I add to it whatever the Ligon is so the
ligand can be any of those six membered
five member or four membered rings and I
make this complex here what does that
look like it looks like my for
Platinum's but one has a broken arm
because I've lost an electron well this
complex is yellow this one is yellow so
I don't know if anything occurred or not
so sometimes we have to add something to
get a reaction to go and we call that
thing a catalyst so the catalyst is used
in this reaction is an acid nitric acid
when I put that nitric acid in there let
it sit in the cold in the dark BAM it
becomes blue so I know that I've gotten
a reaction to occur so now that I have
that reaction I have to try to classify
what it is so we take light which is
similar to this laser light except i
measure a certain frequency and I get
this graph so this graph will tell me
what are the major bands which are the
major bondings so let me have my for
Platinum's back up here again
yes keep your hats on so you have to
hold one end she holds the other okay
you take one in you take that one you
can put your other one down so what's
happening here these two are going to be
that little band these two are going to
be that major band because these they
have lot more of them around than the
other and that light is exciting them
okay you're going to give me these back
so the light of that UV hitting it is
recording some data for me so that's one
piece of data that data will also thank
you that data will also help me with my
laser where should I set my laser light
and I'm going to set it right here at
the top of wherever this major band
occurs so if you notice when I had that
broken arm I have that electron floating
around well there's only certain pieces
of equipment that can be used to measure
that one of those pieces of equipment is
called an e PR machine electron
paramagnetic resonance this is what it
looks like there's a big magnet I put my
sample down in the magnet when it goes
down it's going to be aligned in a
particular direction either my sample is
going to be straight up like I am it's
going to be leaning over in one
direction or is going to be leaning over
in another direction so here I'm the why
the X and the Z direction I'm spinning
and I collect some data what does that
data look like it looks like this so I
see there's one big major thing that's
any called G perpendicular and that has
a particular number that goes with it
this part down here is in the parallel
region
and that has particular number that's
associated with it so the nice thing
about doing chemistry PAB is my platinum
is it to die known blue so when you make
something new you get a chance to name
it so that's the nickname for this one
so that gives me a second piece of data
okay that proves that i have that one I
have that broken arm another piece of
equipment is the ftir well when I look
at this spectra and that's what we call
what we get out it looks a lot different
than this so in this spectrum when you
do it you have to look at the ligand
first by itself so i have to look at my
antibiotic and here it is that's what it
looks like when i put it in that machine
i put it with the plot to them and this
is what i get out so what's the
difference between do these look alike
no so i know that something happened and
it happened around in this region and it
happened down in this region although it
could have been wet a little bit so
again what is this this is what this
equipment looks like I lift up this
chamber I have to use a certain kind of
cell that has to have a certain kind of
property otherwise I won't get the good
results I put it in there hit a couple
buttons I get out this data where these
bands occur tells me what's going on
where because these are particular to
certain complexes so is this a seat oh
is it a NH where is it and when I see
something get blurry or change that
means that that region that's where that
other element is bound so now here's
what I like this is one of my
specialties which is the laser this is
what the equipment looks like and here's
a close-up of the laser one type of
laser this happens to be an argon I and
tube that means that I'm taking that
argon ion hitting the sample that is
placed that in here is being bounced off
and it gets recorded
another instrument so what does that
Spectre look like wow it looks a lot
different than the other because
remember it's kind of sits in the
inverted position like the epr so again
here's the age of the dyno and by itself
and then here is the what I get out when
I put the platinum there well that's
drastically different so there's these
are platitude in Tamar's platinum
residence Robbins this had no platinum
in it but i can still get the resonance
raman if there was no making of a
compound this thing would stay the same
but because i made a compound in this
region where I just have this little
band of 200 I now see that I have a
doublet two bands in this region where I
had about six or seven I now have two
major ones in a minor one so it tells me
again that yes I've made what I've been
looking for so that's what the drugs the
two drugs and and these reactions have
been done with both of these I just
don't have time to show all the data
this thing is called tetra patan a
potassium tetrachlorodrine I use this to
make this compound so sometimes if
something is not pure I want to see if
there's a little D would you get a
reaction with this so i took this free
cursor and almost the same kind of way
of making it as i did with the other
this compound is red i put some water in
it to make it liquid I make this complex
this one stays in solution I add another
ligand and I make a red complex instead
of a blue and so I decided to use that
with some antibiotics because people
like to mix what they're using when
they're doing drugs sometimes so we're
going to talk about one particular one
which is ampicillin when I look at a
person and I'm talking about the
platinum work in that platinum vine it
can buy between this
and this oxygen it combined between this
oxygen and that nitrogen or between this
nitrogen that oxygen this oxygen that
nitrogen these two oxygens or this
nitrogen in that oxygen so I have so
many different places that can buy when
you first make it you get all of those
but there are different ratios in which
these are made the trick is to clean it
up after you've made it so that you can
see which particular complex you have so
one of the major ways to examine that is
using nuclear magnetic resonance again
this is what the equipment looks like
and I have a big magnet so what's the
difference this looks kind of like the
EPR one but it tells me some information
about what's going on so here's the drug
antibiotic by itself there was no
platinum well here it is when I put the
platte in a minute so this is with the
ampicillin but it was also done with
mezlan which is another antibiotic
proposal which is another antibiotic and
penicillin g which is a very common one
so when i look at the platinum in Omar's
i see that each I mean yeah platinum in
Tamar's they're all different so that
tells me something about the complexes
that are formed with each one there are
some pieces of the complex that are the
same so this band stays constant I can
now assign that as to what's going on
this band changed shape but it's still
like in this pretty much the same
position and the same thing is occurring
here
another major technique is x rays so
this is a picture of the x-ray machine
so I put the sample in here's a gas on
cylinder there has to be involved it as
a microscope so the major difference
between this technique and the others
the sample has not only to be a solid it
has to be a crystal in the EPR it can be
a liquid or solid but it doesn't have to
be a crystal it can be a powder and NMR
it can be a liquid or a solid work and
that solid can or cannot be a crystal
and raman that sample can be a solid or
liquid or gas at but that solid does not
have to be a crystal you get the best
data when it is but and then you can
also do powders with this one so this
one has to be solids that can be powders
or crystals so we see that this come I
made this complex and it has four
Platinum's so this complex took over a
year to make so what does that mean it
means that I put the two things together
I put it in the dark in the refrigerator
after i heated them and I kept looking
at it everyday at first then it went to
every week then it went to every month
and then I forgot about it so I made
this one when I was a graduate student
so sometimes when you're a graduate
student your boss will come in and look
in the refrigerator and say what's that
what's that what's that and it had my
name on it so I was like oh I forgot
about it well when we took it to the
x-ray crystallographer here this complex
that formed but this complex took a year
to form so it's a very good complex
medicinally but it takes so long to make
it that it's not useful because you want
something that's quick
the goodness-of-fit represents that as I
take collect that data on several
different occasions and it's several
different runs i should say how good is
the data from each one of those runs
because this crystal structure was based
on all those collections being summed up
how well one compared to the other so as
a scientist want some of the things you
need to ask our what is something that
you want to look at so how did I end up
with one of my things being platinum
it's because sometimes you look around
somebody gets sick they get sicker and
you say well what's going on here people
take stuff that they don't necessarily
tell the doctor that they took so you
want to see what's going on so that's
why how I got into the system arena then
you when you ask yourself the question
what's going on then you need to search
the literature and say has somebody else
thought about this question did they try
to answer this question did they come up
with it if they didn't then that's an
area that you can work on and once you
decide what you want to look at then the
next thing is to say how am I going to
do this so one of the ways that you can
decide how to do it is to look at what
other people have done try up try it
into experiment for a different sample
well a lot of times that doesn't work
but once you've tried you can sit back
and think what can I change and you
systematically change some one thing at
a time to see what will work when things
do not work you ask why and that's
sitting back deciding I need to change
this I need to change that if it does
work then you say well what's the next
thing I can pursue so it's going from
those ligands that was shown in the very
beginning which is six membered five
members four membered down two things
which are big like the antibiotics
because that's something else that
full of taking but most importantly
whatever it is that you do you have to
love what you do because then when
things don't go right it doesn't matter
you keep on working on it because that's
very little it doesn't matter when you
and nothing works all the time when you
get it to work it's like who's your
favorite rapper somebody who's your
favorite rapper do you have a favorite
singer dancer yes what's your name
uh-huh Courtney do you have a favorite
singer dancer nobody you don't have
anything you have one okay do you take
it I wouldn't call him rap but it's that
feeling when something works it's like
you've gone to a Frank Sinatra concert
he looked at you in the audience and
said come on up stage and follow me for
the night so that's what it's like when
something works I happen to like
Ludacris Ludacris came on campus and I
happen to get all the way to the very
front and that's why i can say that
feeling being upfront lunching him
trying to get up on the stage and dance
was the same thing as when something
works you're being it works your idea
was a good one your thought process was
a good one so it makes all those times
when it didn't work worth it so we
always have to thank people because you
never get to where you are by yourself
first and foremost I'm going to thank my
mom because if it wasn't for her I
wouldn't be standing here now this is
the person that was my p.i who
constantly he had me thinking I was
color blind he had me thinking I wasn't
working hard enough but he got me to
where I am this professor met me and
invited me to his lab in Germany and
from there I learned to do things in a
much shorter period of time and this is
my other mentors and here are some
students that I've had here and you
can't do your work if you don't have
money so these are some of the people
who helped me with the funding of what
I'm doing and so I'd like to say thank
you to you as an audience but also to
those who helped me
and does anyone have any questions